this has been your daily dose of
cognitive dissonance but
a fresh reminder that cognitive
dissonance um needs to be dealt with and
if you're angry it's because it just
uh disagrees with your preconceived
notions on life and your preconceived
notions could be incorrect believe it or
not yes we're not always right
so if you want to just hate okay
but understand that you're just hating
and it doesn't mean anything because
emotional skepticism
thought out the window if you can refute
uh you know the points made the
arguments made
that's a different story but since we
are operating under the deen of allah
very unlikely you'll be able to do that
and if you think you have
you're just you're fooling yourself
[Music]
[Music]
how would you feel if mom passed away
knowing you didn't do anything to take
care of her
this is uh this is really good stuff and
it gives
people insight into this type of life
because this is not something that many
people know about so
um the one thing that i want to do here
is i want to kind of restructure this
and bring it into um
more so for muslim women you right
because
let's be honest a lot of the muslim
women are being affected
by feminism they're being affected by uh
liberalism and just all these different
ideologies and
ways of doing things right and with that
being said
you have the traditional values in islam
that are actually starting to be tossed
to the side by many of these muslim
women
um for example there's a lot of muslim
women
that are completely against collision
even though
clearly it says it in the quran you got
a lot of muslim women who
they they literally just want a man
that's going to take care of everything
for them but they are
trying to one up and um kind of like you
said
it's a very uh domineering
type relationship where the woman isn't
a masculine and the man isn't feminine
and and what's crazy
is that the the woman will actually want
this because of the ideology that's
being instilled
upon her because of the things that
she's putting on to herself
thinking that this is correct so
for these chicks what do you have to say
for that
so your question is like what would i
say to a woman who
is not okay with polygamy and what would
you say to a woman who's not okay with
proligently and what would you say
to the women who are muslim
yet they still are taking on
they're adopting these uh ideologies and
these ways of being
where they are being the masculine in
the relationship and they're
being dominant instead of their man
being dominant and i don't even think
they're realizing it too
yeah yeah so with the domineering part
is the best part i'll give you because
that'll lead into the polygamy part
so if you allow yourself to be the
leader all the time with your man
you will lose respect for him and when
you lose respect for him
you will naturally not incline towards
him in intimacy
and then once you decline towards him
towards intimacy he becomes a sort of
slave for you of money just paying the
rent
uh just buying you groceries being your
chauffeur taking you around
you're gonna start to lose respect for
him and you're gonna start to crave
more of a hold
and then you might slip up and cheat on
him
with a man who is not a muslim
but he's perfectly willing to put a belt
around your neck and put you
down and then you're going to go home to
your good muslim man
secretly cheating on him and maybe give
him an std
you might have gotten pregnant you're
going to then take
even more of your energy out on him and
then you will
crave eventually something more than
just having a soft
little soy boy who you've beaten down
because if you beat down your man you
will get
more and more and more
just disgusted with him right and he
doesn't deserve to be abused by you
mentally because
a man who allows himself to be whipped
on too much
eventually you will start hitting him
and he might let you hit him
but you're going to get a false sense of
ego trying to hit him right
so let's say she beats her man because
she's dominated him so much
but then she goes and cheats on him with
a non-muslim man to get
physically intimately satisfied a lot of
these men who are not muslims will
haul off and suck you in the face i mean
i've been
i think a lot of people on my channel
know i've had a lot of fist fights with
men
i grew up in a very violent area i've
seen abuse my mom used to fight a lot
with men
and you know i know what it's like to
have a real man
even though i'm good at martial arts hit
you so hard
that you're black out it's like wow
and you know women who have allowed
themselves to beat on their nice
religious muslim man they get more
powerful they think like oh no man will
ever strike back
but one dude will strike you and he'll
leave you in the street with your shirt
exposed
and walk away from you or he'll snatch
you by the hair and push your face in
the carpet and
really show you like you will not hit me
i am not bound by the rules of allah or
islam
i am a man because see once you abuse
your
your husband you're going to want to try
to cheat and get a sort of
a hit from a real man right they're
gonna crave that energy whether they say
it or not
and or they'll start introducing you
know perverted forms of intimacy with
their man that's why a lot of women now
caution listeners they're pegging their
men
they're buying dildos strap-ons pegging
their men
and then fantasizing or going ahead and
cheating on their religious
partners with men who are not muslim
who will perfectly you know put them in
their place choke them
do abusive things slap them around and
then she becomes more inflated and more
kind of like just
you know and it's going to abuse her man
and you're incurring wrath upon you from
allah
you cannot psychologically abuse your
partner so if you're going to go down
that road of wanting to always be the
one
leading the way of your man you should
have picked a better partner
you need to if you find yourself not
wanting to submit to a man
you pick the wrong one because if you
have a man who is like
this magnetic energy you will sit down
naturally you're like i like this guy
man
he's really nice he's wise he's calm he
calms me down
but if you find yourself wanting to
compete with a man
then you've picked the wrong partner and
that means that you should pick someone
who calms you down not ralls you up
because if a man riles you up and you
want to dominate him that's a clue that
you picked the wrong guy because your
man
is supposed to calm you down he's
supposed to be a rock he's supposed to
be someone who
you can turn to and he exercises your
energy he pulls out the energy from you
in intimacy if you're the one who is
constantly
bashing him complaining nagging you
picked the wrong guy
and you made him softer with the more
abuse because not all men can handle the
abuse
they don't understand what's being done
to them until they've already gone down
the wrong rabbit hole
and see that's where polygamy comes in i
am was before i was a muslim didn't
understand the concept very much but i
realized as i
studied more in islam and i got to see
real muslim men who are masculine
it really does become like the lion and
the pride where you're like
hey these ladies want we want we want to
be with him give him children
let's honor him let's guard and protect
him i want his seed in my belly
i want to give him children i want to be
with him that's like a holy thing and
it's not the uh
pimp way because a lot of the women
think oh it's the pimp way floyd
mayweather with his stripper chicken
heads
no no no no we're not talking just about
lust we're talking about
honoring him with heirs with offspring
it's a different energy where you sit
down like with your legs folded and
you're like wow
like your brain doesn't even think about
arguing about smacking hitting
pulling his beard spitting on him you're
like let me feed you
let me what can i do for you that's how
you know
that polygamy is a necessary and real
aspect that is healthy for men because
it's also
going to keep that man healthy see if
you allow yourself to become the
dominant one and you're always abusing
and dominating your man
slapping him around go here go there
he's not going to be healthy he's not
going to be the leader
and then when you have a crisis and he
can't help you
or a man is attacking you in the street
and he doesn't defend you
you're going to be even more disgusted
and you're like do i got to do it
i'm tired i got to do it and then you
become more resentful towards men
it's nice to have a man who can bear the
burden on the shoulders
it is nice you can see you can be strong
i had to learn this too
i'm a very strong person but the world
is already competing with me i don't
want to compete with my man
i don't want to compete with my partner
we're a team
we're a freaking team we have to be a
unit you know
and if you're with the other women who
are sharing him right your
their wives get along
treat them well if they have a baby
change the diaper
you can be a solid unit that is so
powerful to spread islam when you love
allah and you get a good righteous
muslim man
you are a unit to spread the religion to
spread
his seed and to help the other women
survive as a unit
if you are the domineering one and you
have a wormy weak
man of course you don't want to have a
second wife because you don't respect
him
you don't think he's worth it you think
i i'll get him look at this worm look at
this guy
he's going to get a second wife yeah
right i'm if he's not good enough for me
how are you going to be good enough for
a second one
so of course they won't do it now they
they confuse it with the groupie aspect
you're not a groupie
you're not a side chick you're a wife
duties come with being a wife honor
comes with being a wife
demands come with being a wife a side
chick like because remember i'm
italian so if you have a guy he's a side
chicka gumma
it's like she gets a couple shoes she
gets some nice stuff she's the italian
side chick
but he has his real catholic wife right
a lot of italian men on the east coast
especially you know in the 80s and 90s
like a lot of my family who still lives
in italy
they they have their side chick but they
give her presents
right like okay i cheat on my religious
wife she gets gifts but when
islam is better because you're not a
side chick you're a wife
and with a wife comes responsibilities
like the prophet muhammad peace be upon
him said right you
you have to take care of these wives and
provide for them
and yes you will incline towards one
towards more than the other
but if you don't have an ego and you
realize you're a unit
and that you love allah your duty is to
spread islam
your womb is a tool that will help you
to spread the religion and you love the
religion more than you love yourself
and you honor your man it's not a big
deal it's not a big deal but that's why
the man has to pick
the right type of woman and the woman
has to pick the right type of man
because to me i see polygamy as a
that's the brilliant way to help spread
islam because some women can only have
one kid
they can't have any kids but that's what
makes us different than the christians i
mean mormons had polygamy and then they
were not allowed to have it anymore but
they would have children
and they would live on their states
together and they were a good family
a solid family right it's important
to spread the religion because we're
being muslims are being killed all over
the world
look at china they're in concentration
camps
and china was doing sterilization
programs upon yogurt muslims
right so think about it in gaza they
have buildings falling on little kid's
head you need to be repopulating the
ranks
we need strong men to stay healthy and
them having different wives
also helps the women to compete in
staying beautiful
how many people let themselves go ah i
had my man you know but if you know he's
going to do go soul and go with his
other wife you're like you know what
maybe i will go for a run
maybe i will keep up a little bit of
healthy competition
a little bit of healthy maintenance this
is
is completely different than being a
chicken a brothel or being a pimp's girl
or being a groupie or being a sidekick
there's no honor in that
but when you love allah you understand
how the prophet peace be upon him did it
you find the right guy who his energy
naturally makes you sit down
you're like oh yeah you know it's you
have to do the work and you have to find
it
and the man has to have the character
that naturally makes you
submit in that way but it's a tool that
is
a blessing from a law of mercy but some
women
they think that they got their man just
because they don't share him with other
wives
no society is already trying to take him
away from you so why
have adultery when you he can have a
second wife and you can get along with
her and you can make yourself a team
one does the cooking one does the
laundry one takes the kids out
one is the teacher be mature
i mean it's not that hard but women make
it harder because they want to be the
queen
instead of being the teammate every
woman wants to have the crown on her
head
but it's like no we have to be more than
that take off the crown and let's be a
team
shoulder to shoulder you bear a burden i
bear a burden we're in this together
let's
love this man let's all take care of the
children
let's do it right but it takes a certain
level of dedication to allah
if you're you only care about yourself
your makeup your shoes
of course those women won't do it but
again
the
do you think that
women are just or muslim are against
pollutiony
because of what you said because um
they just don't respect the man they
don't see him as like
a lion or like worthy yeah or
do you do you think it's just because
they just don't want to share
the message play of both because look at
how the media
makes men look like idiots a lot you
look at the popular tv shows
uh even if you have a vpn you can get
past censorship and what your country
allows for you to see
but they make men seem like idiot
drunkards
losers wallets so of course you already
have a
hollywood that's trying to make you see
men as nothing and
they don't have the right type of man
who they'd want to share and they're
in denial about the purpose of a man
about the history of men and how they
used to usually have
spirit you know they used to spread
their seed in that way
and they have a false sense of like i
can hold on to him forever he'll never
get bored of me there's no benefit
i'll always be jealous but let me tell
you
i once and this is a personal story
which is how i know islam is the right
religion
i once caught a partner of mine watching
porn and i punched him in the face i was
a little bit more violent
i was bad okay i was wrong i did it
though
but he wasn't a muslim he was an atheist
but i i got jealous but now it's like
now that i've gone into islam and i've
gotten to see some examples of real men
and you're like
there's no jealousy there
like that's amazing like i would totally
be a second third fourth wife to this
guy he already has four wives but
if he was open to it i would do it and i
was like that's
that's something interesting like like
you have to go through it and see it
but that's the thing is these women have
to find that man and the man has to be
of himself
a real man that's what comes in the male
masculinity
a soft man no it just you can tell like
you ain't gonna you can't find your way
up a paper bag
you know like if the man doesn't command
respect of course
but uh a solid just fortified
disciplined man can do it
i mean so many women they have open
relationships here in california right
the liberal women have uh the bachelor
parties before they get married
they have open relationships or they
call it the 25th surprise
where you're married for 25 years you
let your partner sleep with someone else
there's already a lot of traditions like
that where
after a certain amount of years of being
with someone you let your partner cheat
on you and then you talk about it
there's already a lot of that type of
culture in america
so that's already a sign that people
recognize or they do threesomes
right they do threesomes or they do
other perverted things
but that's the dishonorable route the
honorable route
is a lot or they watch pornography
together
so these women they don't make sense in
their own heads they'll watch porn with
their partner
they know their partner sees other women
on the street they'll sometimes let
their partner sleep with their neighbor
or you know their wife swap they do
double dates they do all these different
things that are already like haram
right and a lot of muslim women will
deny that they do it but
it is pushed by feminists and liberals
to do this
why do that when you can just have a
second wife and you can trust her she
doesn't have stds
you know her face you know she's clean
you know she's a good woman
you can be a team but you have to work
in your character
and you have to make your man fortified
you cannot abuse him
make him soft manipulate him put him
down
and you will naturally see that this
isn't just about you
you're not the queen bee you don't have
to be the leader in the family you're
not the leader in the family
you think you are because of your
comfort
but you're not so i think that you're
right is that
there's a lot of women who don't agree
with polygamy because they don't
they don't see their man as someone
who's earned it men they can work on
that themselves and then those women
will come to them
and he has to be strong to select based
upon that though
because if you get a narcissist woman
well you get what you ask for
you know so it comes down to both the
men and women finding the right
match you know what i'm saying i hope i
explained that well
yeah that was very clear and concise
okay so next question alright next
question
how would a woman a muslim woman begin
to open herself back up to this
to being polygamous yes
well i'd say first off start by getting
healthy
if you have cellulite you go and work
out
you eat bad eat healthy cut off the
also the propaganda meaning turn off the
reality tv
stop listening to the music of these
women magicians who give you
a sort of warped concept of alpha
females you could say
love who you are on your skin encourage
your man to work out
feed him well love him well build him up
to be that
that strong uh prophet-like
figure and then
take a part in selecting the woman have
her come
you know and say like hey you know this
is what the duties will entail can we
get along
can she live in a separate room or a
separate house or how can we do this
you know come together as a unit but you
have to be healthy
you have to have self-esteem so eat good
and cut off
the women who are encouraging you to
just be vain vapid narcissist
egotistic maniacs humble yourself before
allah
work on your relationship with allah
understand that the world
and the everything in it is not
revolving around you
like being a mother understand that as a
woman you have a duty to guard and
protect children
and that having children producing
muslim children is an honor
you have to do those things you have to
take care of yourself
and you have to get off the drinking and
you have to get off the
pornography and you have to break off
those things that are warping up your
your concept like your righteousness
become more righteous
make your partner more righteous and
that will lead the way to it
that's what i say all right so here's a
real question
you being a woman are you coming from
the feminine
angle point of view here when you see a
man
all right which man holds more value in
your eyes the man
that can have multiple women multiple
wives here
or the man that um
i'm not going to say cannot but more so
chooses not to
to be honest i'd rather see him with
multiple women because i'd say hey
he's doing his part to spread the
religion y'all heard it first
what about what about a guy that can't
but choose not to
i would say he's being he's he's made
the choice
and i think he hasn't made the decision
because he hasn't found the right woman
who has presented herself
so i'd say hey man he hasn't found it
well at least he's being good
and he denied it and maybe he has a
reason he just hasn't met the right
woman yet
but maybe he doesn't want the stress and
he has found
the woman he wants but he should have a
duty to produce more muslim children
what do you mean he hasn't found the
right woman like what if he's
found a woman but to him he sees that as
like oh
this is this is the woman this is the
woman for me
so what do you mean by that that he
hasn't found a woman yeah the good way
to think about this would be like how
the prophet saws was monogamous
for like their entire relationship all
the prophets were not monogamous too but
that being said the prophet ali was
saying was politicians
after you know khadijah left so
yeah so allah gave him a command with
aisha right
and she had her purpose to be the mother
of believers
so if you make the choice i still think
that
somewhat people's energy will shock you
like
oh like it'll take you a back and you'll
say you know what
this i need to have more children it
also comes down to a man who might not
use it
he may not choose it because he doesn't
want to have to do the intimacy part all
the time
maybe he's like you know what i can't
perform this much with this woman i
can't afford it
but if he's focused on producing muslim
children
i think he would do it so i think it
comes down to does the man
want to be the father does he want to be
the seed
the gardener in that way so it comes
down to
producing heirs for islam so he might
found the woman who's beautiful
enough and says no but i say it's an
argument of
i have a duty to make islam spread
across the world
you know you have a that's how i look at
it
so he can choose not to okay cool take
care of the one you have
awesome good maybe you can adopt maybe
you can give zakah maybe you can build a
masjid or a school there's other ways he
can spread islam
but for me personally i think it's time
for
a heavy push with all the wars going on
with muslim countries how much death
there is censorship online
constant targeting it's time for babies
to be born and it's time to spread the
religion
so i put it as more of a uh conquest
aspect
i guess that's beautiful because
there's a there's a big push for some
reason
for politically polluting not to happen
and it's weird because it's coming from
the muslims
so to hear this perspective it's uh it's
refreshing
because to hear the other perspective um
it kind of brings thoughts to your head
or as a man it brings us to my head of
like
oh well maybe i should just be with one
woman but when i hear
perspectives like this it's like ah yeah
yeah you know this this seems fitting
this seems like
it it is how it should be we'll
recognize or the feminist liberals want
to reduce the population remember that
they want to reduce the population
because of climate change
and they are openly pushed to reduce
the population on earth that's why they
want you not to eat meat they want you
to be vegans they want you not to drive
your car
they're trying to uh agenda u.n agenda
21.
uh there's a reason why muslims are
being penetrated with that is because
they want to reduce populations in
general
they see humans as a sort of virus on
earth
being a mother is seen of being shamed
upon and islam is the last religion
where
you actually have people who follow
their faith not to be rude
but they actually want it so of course
they're going to target muslim women
with that propaganda they see
oh you have three or four kids you're
doing a curse for climate change
because i live in the liberal areas if
you see the way they talk about the
planet they worship the planet i'm not
saying we shouldn't care about pollution
but they want to reduce the population
that's why there's an abortion clinics
all in the poor areas they want you to
abort your children they make movies
about aborting your children
they glorify the feminists they wear
shirts that say shout your abortion
they glorify baby killing so of course
they're going to target muslim women and
say
don't have more than one wife because
that's a form of uh keeping you from
breeding
it's a form of keeping you in check that
way they can inoculate your men with bad
food
brainwash them and then now you're
reducing your own numbers you're doing
the work for them
right so for me it's like
if you really love your religion and you
want islam to rule
you need to have children that's the
easiest way but see feminists see
birthing as a curse as oppression
i see it as a tool and an asset
right but that comes to how much you
love the law that comes down to
how ready are you it's such an easy way
to
spread islam your womb your healthy man
is there waiting
you don't need to have old like uh you
need the fanciest ipad you need the
fanciest baby clothes
you need to have a fancy baby crib
materialism comes in and you say
well i can't afford to have a kid
because i can't afford all this toys for
it
man that's not how it works have the
children
spread his seed raise muslim children
replace the children who are dying adopt
do it it's such an easy way but
they love look i mean come on if they
won't even take off their makeup
to worship allah of course they're not
going to want to have another wife
i mean come on you know like this where
you have to pick the right women some
girls
some girls are confused with that
statement but they don't know that
you're will do
i'm just speaking like from a
perspective i'm not talking about like
what you
you know what's between you and allah
that's between you and allah but
strictly islamically speaking if you
have makeup you will do is kind of
nullify it
right let's let's keep a hundred percent
because you have to do what do we have
to do abolition
exactly so you will do is not going to
be fully valid
i don't know if your salah is going to
be fully valid right it's not for me to
judge but
you have to get your face wet you have
to get your face wet
if you put your wetness on your makeup
it's going to smear
and so i don't want to apply it again
it's expensive it's mac
they think going like this with their
hands with air is like some no the
hadees are clear
you know if it's clear but they're
addicted
because they're programmed to it by
narcissists
you know type of women who are very vain
and vapid and surface level
oh wear the mask of makeup be put on the
filter
you know no forget about the makeup
forget about the handbags and the nails
produce muslim children but again they
put
their materialism before their man and
before god
you know it's it's quite sad but it's
it's intelligent if you study psychology
you study warfare you study eugenics
you study political systems and
ideologies it's so clear
how they target muslim women i mean it's
it's really not that hard to see
but the women won't they don't want to
accept because they don't want to change
but men you don't need to change the
women just pick better women
really i mean don't get a woman who you
have to fix
get a woman who's already doing it and i
mean bada bing bada boom as they say
you pick a better woman who is ready to
spread islam and it wants to have
children who's fertile
if you can't give up makeup for god of
course they're not going to want to
like have a second wife they already
love makeup more than their own god
more than allah i mean that's rude to
say but i don't want to hear any if sans
or but about it i've
i've dealt with those kind of women
they're just lying to themselves because
it hurts their feelings
they don't want to admit how insecure
they are how addicted they are to the
makeup
but they don't want to admit it let it
go the makeup
use your womb your womb is like a tool
man it's just it's such an easy way to
spread more muslim babies
but they want a career chase they don't
want to look ugly while pregnant they
say they don't want to look fat
because they're afraid their man will go
with someone else it's like
a baby is potential
baby is potential give your man
sons and daughters your breasts feed
them with your own breasts and
make them grow and be healthy it's such
an easy way
such an easy way but it's you know in
the abortion culture what do you expect
you know okay i gotta i got a question
for that so
um angel right new muslim
i'm just gonna create a hypothetical
scenario he's single
not married i don't know if he wants to
get married anytime soon i don't know if
he wants to
you know if he's looking but what i do
know for a fact is
if i was in his shoes and i was single
and i'm here with all these muslimas
that might not really be hit
i i would be like bro i'm i can't find a
good woman
so where do people that are new reverts
where do
people that just came into islam want to
get married want to
kind of help lower the gates where do
they find these women that you're
talking about
you're asking me or him yeah you you
know
i that's a good question i think social
media is a powerful tool but we have to
create the networks
people have to start creating those
types of groups
and if these women like me create
youtube channels and we start
networking with each other we can create
it they may not exist
but we have to talk about it we have to
make it ourselves we can't sit around
waiting for any mom to help us
but to supplicate to allah we have to do
it youtubers supporting each other
saying their honest views and more women
will say i'm like that i'm like that i'm
like that and then we can network
as a cohesive unit right
so i think you'd have to use social
media you have to be in person
you have to go hunting well find the elk
as they say
you're gonna go find the great white
shark get in the boat you got to go out
there give dawah you know
do everything you can and pray to allah
and maybe that woman will come in your
path
but we have to verbalize it you know we
have to say it
and then someone will hear the call and
come
i believe allah will do that if we say
it we give the call
those women will wake up i'm like that i
didn't know i was but i am here i
am right that'll help because that's
what i'm going to do and
a lot of women are shy to say it but why
if you care about your religion you care
about allah and you really feel allah
inside you
you recognize that muslims are under
attack
they are coming and they are hitting you
hard
and your makeup is not anything your
bags your job your career
spread the religion because if we really
believe this world is temporary
having children and spreading male seed
is a duty
you know already your house is not
coming with you your car is not coming
with you
your ipad your iphone your playstation
none of it is coming
but what you leave behind you can leave
behind ten children
you can leave behind a legacy a
bloodline
right that honors allah and yes some
children might become atheists they
might
go astray but you tried you tried
your room is a tool it's powerful
embrace motherhood don't kill your own
children
don't withhold your legs from your man
give him what he needs he will give you
what you need
and it'll be better but we have to talk
about it ourselves and create those
networks
that's what i'd say i agree 100
raw me you've been awfully quiet the
whole episode bro
subhanallah i don't think i've said a
word
[Laughter]
alhamdulillah i know exactly what's
going on yet
what's going on my head enlighten us
you've accepted pollution
what's going through your head bro
because i know
i don't know bro like i'm literally
imagining if i were you and i'm a new
muslim
bro i would be like what's been six
months
since you reverted brah would not be
okay being single
i don't know
let the man be what the man
how about you romy what what's the
question
same question to you well what was the
question though
i wasn't listening
how you bro how are you going to say
that
all i all i heard was i would not be
okay being single
because you've been a viewer yeah and he
has a fiancee bro
y'all putting me on the spot not 100
well let's talk about milan are you kind
of are you
do you see yourself getting married to a
guy in the near future or is that
something
that you're kind of waiting till you
found the right guy well
i want someone who's like the level of a
sheikh or any mom a scholar
i'll be honest i've had bodybuilders in
the past
i've had enough of the carnal stuff with
the american eyes dating
very alpha man very you know very good
man alhamdulillah
we separated but it is what it is but
i want a real muslim man who's like a
scholar who can make me a better muslim
i need somebody who's smarter than me
more discipline than me
and who is strict so when i find him
i'm going to give him children let's put
it that way i don't care if he has
four wives or three wives whatever's
permissible under a law
let me in let me and i'll say you know
let me in
i'll give you children and i have skills
cooking cleaning whatever needs to be
done
alhamdulillah let's do it i'll hunt for
you whatever it is i'll fish for you
whatever it is but you have to be a real
muslim
right i don't want a lot of young men
come right and it's like you're 25
because i'm 30
you know and it's like i'm sorry it's
like you're too young
you you you're too young you're not even
if you're very in the dean
you're too young i need someone in the
40s maybe even their 50s who's like
a scholarly mom someone who's who's
there
who's there you know what i'm saying i
don't want to be led astray
i've had enough time with the carnal
side you i want someone who's real
and to honor them with children so when
that comes along to love
it'll arrive but i supplicate you know i
supplicate
and some women say you shouldn't say
that don't say that because
you know in a mom or they'll never want
you if you say that and it's like
okay if you don't say what you want how
are you gonna
help that you have to let people know
because other women might be like hey i
want that too
so during ramadan i supplicated for that
and allah will decide
allah will decide but i'll still help a
lot of children right
give to charities help my neighbors out
volunteer at the schools i'll still make
sure i can help as many children as
possible
and you know do my dowel part and
perfect myself every day
but only allah decides what bounty
you'll get and if i don't get it in this
life
alhamdulillah on the hair after there
might be something there you never know
so fast forward that's real yo this
this woman needs to be the voice for the
muslim man bro
listen except for the uh going after
guys that are like
40 to 50 like let the women you know
choose what age they want yeah oh yeah
yeah
yeah what you're saying is real
thank you not vibe with it oh thank you
romney come on man say something
i think i think you were just the the
amount of just
fire that you were spitting like he's
just like out of breath
he doesn't even know what to say
there have been a few a few moments uh
where i thought of certain things to say
but um obviously
i had to let the sister talk masha'allah
she was on a roll for like the entire
episode something that really held it
down and i think she got the uh
very very important messages messages
out there um
one thing i want to say for the question
about angel like uh
you know where do you go to find a good
muslim man or woman
may allah grant him pious spouses
and children will be the coolness of
islam his eyes i mean allam to be a
leader for the righteous
but but i don't think there's a place to
go right if there is a place to go
everyone
would be heading down there right and
then i would be corrupted by all the
wrong
types of muslims but um there is no
place to go and i i think that's why it
really comes down to the man or the
woman as an individual which we've been
talking about
this entire episode because um you're
gonna get some good suitors and some bad
suitors and it's up to you
to vet them yourself um so there are
some places that are better to go to
right like it's probably better and more
ideal to meet someone through a family
friend than at the mall
but it's possible that the person me at
the mall is better than the family
friend
um so i think it you know all
comes down to us as individuals since we
don't have a proper system
living where we live and this is like
this is the thing people don't
understand people think we have it easy
we don't have easy we actually have a
very difficult
um comp even compared to some other
places in the world we had a brother
recently talking about the place he
lives and is just beginning to get
corrupted with liberalism and secularism
we are corrupted we are liberalism and
secularism so we
we have to understand that we're
actually fighting a battle
uphill we don't have it easy we actually
have a very difficult and if
you know as brother mahdi said in the
episode very good episode mashallah go
check it out
um if you're not progressing you're
regressing so if you're not actively
trying to make yourself better
up here and here and everywhere in every
way shape and form connecting to allah
um and strengthening that connection
then you're gonna regress and you're
gonna go down this
liberal secularist path and that's going
to lead you
down the path every you know what the
sister was talking about just now
subhanallah
exactly exactly so we can if we make the
networks ourselves
we can do it we have to lead by example
like
what's doing this is a phone of it
because somebody might watch it be like
you know what i'm going to create a
an after school club i'm going to create
a speaker's corner in my neighborhood
i'm going to do this not that's how we
do it you have to step forward
and put it out there in the world yeah
i've been thinking a lot recently that
we need some kind of sharia in some way
shape and form
uh in the west like we need sharia
courts and we need
to do them right islam needs like islam
needs to have its own
like even if it's under canadian law
because it must be if we live in canada
or american law if you're in america
we need to have some kind of force some
kind of power like
even if it's like during the marriage
contract being able to go to the man's
house
and uh take money or take something else
to take child support
take the woman's rights islamically like
if you are truly
secular then you should allow for some
kind of
um institution like that that will give
muslim people who uh you know
cherish islam and their deen to sign up
for something like that to be a part of
something like that
and i think we should really push for
that because until we have some kind of
law and accountability
for both men and women we're still
living under the same
laws fighting the uphill battle so i
think that uh would be a huge step
inshallah
agreed all right let's start a
shiria court you guys made it this far
hashtag sharia
if there's anything else let us know
any of you it was
there was something for sure but i
completely forgot
all right what was uh what was the last
thing you were talking about on
three of courts no before that are you
uh you're single bro
um living in the the west you're
fighting an uphill battle
yeah but that's why we all have to come
forward and create networks
we have to be unified yes be unified
and that's a key component to be unified
because
like you have to be you literally have
to be
you cannot be distant we have to use the
internet as a tool to unify
yeah i'm just wondering uh what's your
favorite
hadith or ayat from the quran just
something that
really vibes and resonates with you as
soon as you're ready you just knew like
where it all of them where they talk
about have you not walked across the
earth and see what was of those before
that the ruins right that you can be
replaced
that allah guides whom he wills and
these are straight whom he wills but
basically the one where you walk through
the earth and see what was the end of
those who came before
that one is powerful because i am a very
big
nerd you know i'm into architecture and
you know think about the romans the
aztecs the mayans
the incas every single dynasty of china
right i think just up and down up and
down you're like wow
so when we see the secularists today
pretending that robots are going to save
the future
you're like honey what does allah say
you know that one is what i like the
most
yeah the hadoop is where the boudines
are involved the bedouins i
always pronounce it wrong those are
always my favorite because they remind
me a lot of myself
and he had to deal with a very
strong-headed kind of like
very solid people because i was very out
there as a child running on train tracks
and stuff like that so the
all the deals where the prophet has to
deal with the
like very blunt uh words of the badoons
the bedouins
is like oh he has patience you know he
has patience and to deal with them
and there's their strong kind of almost
stubbornness you know
and the patience you have to have so i'd
say those are hadiths are always my
favorite always my favorite
mashallah there's also a hadith where
he talks he points to a woman and says
shall i show you the women of paradise
and it was a woman who she was one of
the captives and she was
nursing all the children from her
breasts so
um she's like taking one child giving
him next child giving them
next child giving them he says that's
the woman of paradise i'm summarizing it
but
that one is kind of like how i saw
myself it's so like okay it doesn't
matter
if the child needs to eat the child
needs to eat i don't care if it's mine
or someone
else's child needs to eat the nurturing
aspect
you know that's that's what i that's
another one yeah
i feel like there's so many women that
are gonna get mad at hearing the hadith
but my question is who the hell else is
going to do it
who the man the men going to take pills
and like after two years
grow something like you know men can
actually
produce i'm not going to say they can
produce milk but they can
they can produce a milky substance if
they have very high product in them
yeah yeah it's nasty yeah
oh my man nursing i'd be like go over
his head
if you made it this far also write down
hashtag prolactin
comment down below write two comments
write five comments really helps the
algorithm
it's videos like this that will get
censored will get demonetized but we
really don't care
it's videos like this that will not be
promoted in the algorithm
it's all good hashtag hashtag
milky hashtag collisiony
hashtag
hashtag only fans no no no
no no no no
no no we'll get the wrong type no no
that's horrible yeah yeah you're right
well maybe we'll get the right type
we'll get the people who are looking
for only fans and then they become
enlightened
yeah i never thought about that
all right is there any other message
that you have
for anyone watching any last closing
words
i'd say before you get mad at me the
things i say just honestly
be alone and hear what i said because i
know from experience
and i know what i'm talking about
so hear me out and don't just blow up my
dms with hate
i don't hate women and i don't hate men
i love allah more
than i love anything else and every day
i work harder
and you should do i mean
and y'all y'all better get used to her
because this is the new voice
of the muslims she's uh she's going to
be leading
the future generations of 1000 000 so i
have a feeling this is not going to be
the first time
having a feature with you but with that
being said rami
all right inshaallah uh before i do i
want to say this has been your daily
dose of cognitive dissonance
but a fresh reminder that cognitive
dissonance
um needs to be dealt with and if you're
angry it's because it just
disagrees with your preconceived notions
on life and your preconceived notions
could be incorrect
believe it or not yes we're not always
right so if
you want to just hate okay but
understand that you're just hating and
it doesn't mean anything because
emotional skepticism
thought out the window if you can refute
uh
you know the points made the arguments
made that's a different story
but since we are operating under the
dean of allah very unlikely you'll be
able to do that and if you think you
have
you're just you're fooling yourself but
with that being said uh may allah bless
his sister for joining us and the the
two brothers beside me
uh especially on him may allah increase
him and everything and i'm gonna leave
that
i mean y'all y'all really putting me on
like this i'm putting you listen i'm not
in resistance i'm ready for
multiple wives if that is what allah has
planned
yes it may allah you can't have multiple
lives if you don't have one wife bro
how would you feel if mom passed away
knowing you didn't do anything to take
care of her
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
me